i feel like since we did the madman
quotes right out of the gates we should
have a washington
story as our lead today given the
previous culture there not
obviously the current culture there but
let's start with von miller
broncos linebacker march 16 deadline for
an 18 million dollar option the last
year of
his contract no criminal charges
will be filed against von miller now
there was a vague police investigation
that led to an even more vague
referral to prosecutors which has led to
a
far less vague conclusion that he won't
be charged we don't know what
they were considering charging him with
but reportedly he won't be charged
hey miles the way the nfl handles the
personal conduct policy that doesn't
necessarily end it unless they want to
end it if they don't want to end it they
can continue to pursue it
they can investigate they can suspend
they can do whatever they want to do
so if i'm the broncos i'm still not 100
certain there's not going to be an issue
for vaude miller but the bigger issue is
do you pay the guy 18 million dollars
in 2021 i think at a minimum they're
going to have to
work on that before they keep him on the
team yeah no doubt
i i just don't see why you would keep
him around for that much
money if you do want him to continue to
be on the team and it seems like they do
both uh george payton talking this week
and then vic fangio talking this week it
seems like they would like to have
von miller back but at the same time i
think that there is going to have to be
some type of restructuring in order for
him to not only be back but
to be back at a number where they're
comfortable
based on where the salary cap is going
to be because as we know and as we
continue to see
so many guys are either getting cut or
are restructuring
because of the way the salary cap is
going down this year for 2021 then that
is happening of course because of the
pandemic so i would assume
that if von miller is going to be back
it's going to be at a lower price tag
mike
and miles i can't help but wonder
whether there's going to be some big
name that stuns us all that gets cut
between now and march 17 when all teams
have to be in compliance
with the 2021 salary cap it won't stun
us if von miller is cut because
that's on the radar screen fairly big
name super bowl 50 mvp didn't play last
year 18 million i think too rich for
denver's blood
and it's a ben roethlisberger type of a
situation
how much can they squeeze him how much
will he agree to take below what he's
entitled to get
and would he be interested in playing
for your cleveland browns for example
with miles garrett or some other team
that is more likely to contend this year
than the broncos would he's got that
power to say no
set me free and off you go the denver
broncos will not be setting free safety
justin
simmons he'll be franchise tagged again
at a 20
bump over last year salary cap doesn't
matter for him if you've already been
tagged
you get your next tag at a 20 raise
13.729 million
that is a lot for a safety and
what it does miles it gives justin
simmons all the leverage because
and this is like dak prescott it's very
simple he's got 13.729 million
in hand plus next year he'll become a
free agent
he will hit the open market they're not
going to tag him again next year because
next year to take quarterback money
to keep justin simmons for a third
franchise tag
so he can take that or whatever the
broncos offer that is at least as good
as that you compare the two and you make
your decision so
a lot of leverage for simmons i know the
broncos want to sign into a long-term
deal
13.729 million is the starting point for
year one and it goes
up from there so they better be ready to
dig deep and makes it even more likely
they won't be able to keep von miller
exactly and the funny thing is i always
call this especially the second year of
that franchise tag it becomes a poor
get-off-the-pot situation right because
either you're actually going to do this
and you're going to commit
to long-term to this player that you
have now tagged twice
or you're just saying you know what this
is the last year that we're going to be
able to do this because as you just said
mike
based on the way the franchise tag works
you can't really tag this guy again
you're not going to ever pay a safety
quarterback money and you really
shouldn't because that is one of those
positions
where you can find somebody else who can
at least do an adequate job
if not you know a pro bowl or second
team all-pro job
like justin simmons and i feel like i
should point out no relation
was able to do last year for the denver
broncos so
he's a very good young player i mean we
just showed the graphic of where he was
on our top 100 list of free agents and
i think the broncos would do well to
sign him to a long-term deal
however if they can't if simmons feels
like you know what i'm gonna probably be
able to make more money on the open
market next year
then i can understand why he wouldn't
necessarily want to be in this spot in
denver
where contention is not necessarily all
that guaranteed
the balance for him is a little more
delicate than it would be for a dak
prescott or a quarterback because
the injury risk the wear and tear
despite what happened last year to dak
prescott it was a fluke thing for the
most part quarterbacks are less likely
to become physically beaten down over
the course of a year
justin simmons would have to carry that
injury risk and the risk that all of a
sudden he's not as good as he was after
a year
and he gets the 13.729 million
plus whatever he gets next year assuming
that risk that maybe he won't be as
attractive next year but
that's the challenge for the broncos now
that the tag has been applied and we're
just four days away from the closing of
the window and presumably the broncos
just decided we know we're gonna do it
we're not to bridge the gap between now
and monday the gap
is too big let's go ahead and apply it
so everyone knows
no one will be tempted to try to tamper
with him this weekend and
we've gone ahead and done the safe thing
and we take no chance remember it was
the broncos once upon a time
with the elvis doomerville contract the
fax machine
snafu probably back when you were in
middle school it feels like it was that
long ago miles but uh
you don't want to take any chances with
failing to get your paperwork to the
league office on time
no you don't i mean the browns had a
situation like that uh with the trading
deadline a couple of years ago and they
were trying to get aj mccarron although
one might argue that that one worked out
probably better for the brown since that
fax didn't go in mike
and there's that that theory that was
making the rounds that
up who was the uh who was the guy that
was running the office then the front
office
sasha brown sasha brown accidentally
accidentally failed to get the paperwork
in because hugh jackson wanted aj
mccarron and sasha brown
didn't it was 2014 so it wasn't that
long ago no wait
2013 2013 that the
fax machine snafu help and it happened
in elvis dumerville ended up
being released by the broncos
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports